One of the most important abstract
data structures today is a graph.
Graph analysis is everywhere.
Every day, people are analyzing
physical structures, like buildings and
bridges, electrical circuits,
social networks, just to name a few.
Now, this lesson introduces
parallel graph algorithms for
one especially important primitive.
It's called a a breadth first search,
or BFS for short.
[SOUND] That's breadth as in wide.
This kernel is so important that
there's even a ranking of the world's
supercomputers based on how
quickly they can do a BFS.
Now there's another lesson to look at
supercomputer scale algorithms for BFS.
But in this one you'll consider
a practical algorithm for
the Dynamic Multithreading Model.
So with that quick intro,
let's go explore!